CORNELIUS WILLIS: Hi.
I'm Cornelius Willis.
I'm with the Cloud
Platform team at Google.
And today we're going to have
a conversation about container
technology.
In fact, you might say
a grown up conversation.
And we've got some leaders from
the container software industry
here to share
perspectives with us.
Starting with Alex Polvi,
who is the CEO of CoreOS.
We also have Craig McLuckie who
leads the product management
team that works on
containers here at Google.
And Kit Colbert, who's the
CTO for the cloud-native
applications effort at VMware.
And with that,
we'll get started.
We have questions
for all of you.
CRAIG MCLUCKIE: All right.
CORNELIUS WILLIS:
So, first of all,
why does anybody care
about container technology?
Why are we even having
this conversation?
Why does it matter?
KIT COLBERT: You want
to take that one, Craig?
CRAIG MCLUCKIE: Maybe
I'll take this one.
So I think about
container technologies
as being important
for two reasons.
The first reason
is, what is today.
And then second part of it is,
where's it going in the future,
right?
And both of these
are worth discussing.
The first part of it, today,
as exemplified by Docker,
is that container technologies
have solved a really hard
problem around the hermetic
sealing and deployment
of an application.
So they've taken something
that has historically
been very fraught, and
difficult, and occasionally
fails to becoming something
that's very predictable
and has a great developer
experience around it.
And so they've solved
this hard problem
in a way that's
accessible to engineers.
And engineers like
it for that reason.
The second thing I think
a lot about containers
is, where containers are going.
And if you think about
it, containers really
grew up as a technology
in the internet giants
because it's the
only practical way
to accomplish
internet-scale computing.
Now as we look to the
future, every enterprise
is on the cusp of needing to
act as internet company, as IoT,
and mobile-enabled
workforces emerge.
They need access
to the capabilities
that have previously
been the providence
of the internet giants alone.
And what I see containers
technologies doing
is really moving
the world forwards
into this cloud-native
computing paradigm,
and letting everybody benefit
from the same paradigms
of computing that people like
Google, Facebook, or Twitter,
or others have had to sort
of build for themselves
and pioneer for themselves.
CORNELIUS WILLIS: So if
we think about a world,
before and after, right?
What is container
technology replacing?
And what will
[INAUDIBLE] replace?
What are we doing now
today that we're not
going to do in the future, when
everything running containers?
KIT COLBERT: Yeah,
I mean, one thing
I wanted to add
to Craig's point,
actually, on the
previous question,
was that I think a lot of times
when we use the word container,
we actually bring in a lot
of other concepts with that.
Right?
There's one thing
around basically what
container technologies
like Docker have done,
which is provide like a
great packaging framework
and then the Docker
engine orchestration
framework on the Linux host.
But there's a lot of other
aspects to the application,
and the way the application
that is produced,
that I think really derive like
the kind of end-to-end benefits
that folks are you looking for.
So containers are
absolutely enabling,
and they're awesome, right?
And they're great.
But then there's questions like
the application architecture.
And so a lot of that is
breaking down these more
monolithic
architected apps to be
something you might call
distributed or micro services.
And as you do that, you
enable your development teams
to start moving
more independently,
build more agility, into that.
Then there's things like
continuous integration
and continuous deployment, that
are whole process around how
you really optimize and automate
the software development life
cycle.
So I think it's really
important to point out,
that when you say
containers, a lot of times,
people think about this,
you know, they kind of see
all these different
pieces, which
each have specific
areas and names
and technologies behind them.
But then there's kind
of the actual container
technology that you were
talking about, Craig, as well.
So I think it's important
to kind of distinguish
that there's many different
pieces here going on.
CORNELIUS WILLIS:
Well, I mean, we've
talked about almost every part
of software development life
cycle, and this
touches on everything.
KIT COLBERT: It is.
And I think, you
know, to get it back
to Craig's point,
this notion around how
every company's kind of becoming
like a web scale internet
company.
I think it's absolutely true.
You know, I think it was
Marc Andreessen, right, four
or five years ago now, that
was saying that, you know,
software's eating the world.
It was a big op ed in
the New York Times.
And his point there
was that, company's are
by and large becoming software
companies in the sense
that software is how they
engage with their users.
And is, by and large, how they
differentiate their products.
Right?
Doesn't matter what
industry you're in,
you're kind of becoming
a software company.
So it's one example
of this, right ?
So this company John Deere,
they blog very publicly
about the kind of
transformation they made.
So this is, again, a company
that does tractors, combines,
that sort of thing.
And yet the value
to their customers
is no longer just the
tractor that they build.
It's actually the sensors they
put on the tractor, the fact
that it beams that
up to the cloud.
They have this big
data analytics platform
that runs in the cloud.
And that information then goes
back down to the tractors,
so they can then
optimize and maximize
the productivity of the land.
And that's what they're
really producing.
So think about that transition,
right, as a company.
And what John Deere has
been very vocal about
is their use of containers
and continuous integration
and deployment, all these other
things that have come together
to really differentiate them
as a business in the software
world.
So I think that's
kind of I think if we
ask the why, that's the why.
Because if John Deere didn't do
it, someone else would come out
and they'd make an OK tractor
and an awesome analytics
platform and they would
eventually beat out John Deere.
Right?
So I think that's the kind
of competitive environment
that is starting to form.
CORNELIUS WILLIS: Software
is a competitive weapon.
KIT COLBERT: It is, absolutely.
It's a huge differentiator.
CORNELIUS WILLIS: So
myths about containers.
Who's got some myths that we
need to bust about containers?
ALEX POLVI: Definitely
have some myths.
Like there's a bunch of the
myths rolling around right now.
One big one is that containers
replace virtual machines,
for instance.
I think.
KIT COLBERT: Yeah, that's
one that we hear a lot.
CORNELIUS WILLIS: You agree?
ALEX POLVI: So here's
the big picture.
So container as this
little bit unit,
yeah, it does kind of
resemble a virtual machine,
if you like squint
at it the right way.
But when we're talking
about containers,
we're really talking
about this thing
that Craig alluded to, which
is this way of managing
infrastructure that the
hyperscale guys have
done for a while now, but hasn't
been done really in enterprise.
And the difference there,
is with a virtual machine,
what you do is you
take a big server
and you carve it up into
lots of little servers
and you treat them as like
their own little servers.
With containers, you
take a set of containers,
and you deploy them, and you
manage them as one big machine.
So it allows you to
string a set of machines
as if it was one giant thing.
It's this idea of managing
a data center as a computer,
as one.
And that has a lot of benefits
around letting the software do
the optimization,
of utilization,
or letting it help the
operations team actually
keep things up and
available, and so on.
So if you think about it
that way, a little bit bigger
picture than just
that container,
it's kind of
completely different.
One other one, just call out
and let you guys go after that,
is around security.
So, containers have gotten a
pretty bad rap for security,
but we have to step
back for a moment
and think about, what were
you doing before containers.
And what you were doing
before containers,
is you were just running a
bunch of different applications
on one machine.
And if any of those things
got compromised in any way,
the attacker now can go
get the rest of the server.
And it's rather
trivial from there.
At least with containers,
you're putting up
some boundaries and walls
between every single individual
application.
Really, the only way that
you could do that previously
is if you launched a full
server virtual machine
for one application,
which, you know,
it sometimes happens, but
isn't the like typical use
case of server infrastructure.
So even today, the containers
have gotten a lot of criticism
for security, but
then you just stop
for a second, wait a
minute, before this you
were just letting everything
kind of go to town, but--
CRAIG MCLUCKIE: So let
me add to the first one.
And maybe Kitt wants to
talk to the second one.
Just by-- there's some
interesting conversation
to be had there.
I think Alex is exactly right.
I think the biggest
mistake people make around
containers today is they think
about it the same way that they
think about that
virtual machine.
And there's a couple
of things that
are really important that
one needs to consider.
The first is, with
containers you're
creating something that is
far more automatic and easily
schedulable.
So if you think about
the way that people
tend to run virtual
machines, you
build something in
a virtual machine,
it'd be vertically scalable.
You could add, you know,
additional resources
by creating
additional processes,
but eventually you'd get to
the boundaries of your system.
And then the wheels
would fall off.
You would have to
really kind of change
your sort of way of thinking.
You'd have to make this
big, bold transition
into a distributed
systems, as well.
It was really hard.
So it was easy for
people to build systems
that would scale
to point, but it
was practically impossible
for most engineers
to build systems
that got beyond that.
And one of the things
I think that, you know,
we have an opportunity to do,
as we move towards containers,
is to think about the
item of deployment
as being at the process
level rather than as
at the sort of subsystem level,
and creating a very natural way
to tie these things together
in a useful fashion.
So they can be easily, you
know, stood up, consumed,
scaled, you know,
turned up, turned down.
And by doing so, producing
tremendous value for the end
consumer, because you get
far more efficient use
of your resources,
you don't have
to worry about scaling events,
the health of your system
is managed for you, and you
get far more insight into how
things are behaving because
you're operating at this higher
abstraction.
I think that's an incredibly
key construct as we
look to the next ten years.
KIT COLBERT: Yeah, and I'll
say, I think on that note,
when people think
of VMs, you know,
there's multiple aspects to it.
I like to just decompose into
two simple aspects of VM.
There's kind of the VM as
the packaging mechanism,
right, that you
can install in OS
and put an app in there,
create a VM template, then
provision that thing, you
know, as much as you want.
And there's also the VM
as the runtime vehicle.
And I think that,
you know, what we
see is VM packaging was kind of
a necessity before containers
and just with a lot of
traditional applications,
especially more off the
shelf applications where
you didn't control it.
You didn't have in-house
development able to change it.
And it was kind
of the way it was.
And so, VMs offer great
flexibility there.
But as we get into
the container world,
it makes a lot more
sense, if you can,
to package an application
inside a container.
I think our point
of view, of course,
is that we think we can bring
a lot of the benefits of the VM
runtime to containers, right,
from a runtime scenario.
But I think the other
point I would make, just
on the misconceptions
around containers,
is that again this notion that--
when we think of containers,
again, the association
with that is typically
like a Google-style
type infrastructure.
I've got his awesome
app, which is
like highly
distributed, and totally
resilient to
infrastructure failure,
and all these great things.
And then people say, OK, well,
I can take my old, you know,
20-year-old, legacy,
monolithic app,
toss that thing in a container,
and boom, I'm good to go.
Right?
It's like the magic pixie dust.
And all of a sudden
this thing is
highly scalable and resilient
to hardware failure.
And it's like actually, no.
The container is very helpful,
but if your application--
it's very helpful
in the sense-- let
me finish that thought--
very helpful in the sense
of, you know, being
able to reliably
and quickly reinstantiate
that application
on any infrastructure you want.
But if the application
is broken, doesn't scale,
falls over a lot, they're going
to have a broken, not scalable
application that falls over a
lot reinstantiated a thousand
times faster.
So I think the big
thing that I always
talk to customers about is,
and users about, is like,
hey, guys, you not only need
to think about containers,
you also need to think about
application architecture.
Because that's the
much harder thing
to do, with how do you
actually re-architect the app
to take advantage of these, kind
of this distributed paradigm.
CORNELIUS WILLIS: Right.
It's not a lift and
shift to your old app,
that suddenly your
old app is magical.
KIT COLBERT: Yep.
And, again, that's maybe
another VM comment there,
because the VM enabled that
sort of lift and shift.
But with containers,
you can do that,
but you don't get all
the benefits, right?
To really realize
the full benefits,
you need that sort of rethink
on the architecture side.
CRAIG MCLUCKIE: One
kind of additional point
to make there is--
I agree with you.
I think there's a big
sort of cognitive shift
that needs to happen,
but it's far less big
than the cognitive shift
has ever been before.
If you think the
bad old days of sOA
I don't know if either of you
worked on SOA technologies.
ALEX POLVI: Someone
who does XML, right?
CRAIG MCLUCKIE: Uh, yeah.
Or tried to deploy an
enterprise service bus.
The process of actually
getting to the goodness
of this distributed
systems, you have
to make these huge investments.
You'd have to retrain
all your engineers
around these new patterns.
And you'd have to, you
know, re-architecture
systems to actually
use specific protocols.
And it was a disaster,
because the energy curve
was like-- the value
proposition was there.
It was possible to achieve
these patterns of operating
previously, but there was such
a cognitive hurdle to get over,
it was practically impossible.
And so, I think one of things
that we're starting to see now
is, you know, Docker
has made it easy to kind
of encapsulate something in
a hermetically sealed unit.
Modern sort of technologies
that are actually scheduling it
make it feel like
it's just, you know,
running in a reasonably
local environment.
But you can use SDN to
wire things together.
You can use software-defined
storage to actually map volumes
in, create a natural
experience, but actually
start benefiting from lot
of the values of this higher
abstraction, which
is very powerful.
CORNELIUS WILLIS: So it feels
like it's the right time.
KIT COLBERT: Well, I think
that's a really good point.
I think that's an
excellent point.
Because I think what
you're kind of getting
to is this whole
notion of, you know,
the infrastructure architecture
and the application
architecture stack, it
is evolving as well.
CRAIG MCLUCKIE: Yes.
KIT COLBERT: Whereas before, you
had to do a lot of this stuff
yourself and figure out a lot of
these hard kind of distributed
systems problems.
You know, implement your own
Paxos or whatever it is, right?
What we're seeing now is a lot
of this stuff is available,
many times open source.
And so rather than
you figuring it out,
you can rely on some
other component to do it.
You can focus much
more quick, I think
this is your point,
on the business
logic of whatever the specific
thing is that you're building.
And not have to worry
about all, like the 10,000
other kind of problems
that go along with that.
But you have these
libraries of frameworks
that you can use out of the box.
CORNELIUS WILLIS: So
what needs to happen
in the industry, that isn't
happening now, for containers
really to take hold?
What are the hurdles
we need to get over?
ALEX POLVI: Here.
Here's where we're
at right now with it.
It's this whole
new platform, OK?
And I like to use the
analogy of a phone.
OK?
Imagine if your iPhone
or Android booted up,
and there was no apps on it.
And the first thing you
had to do as a business
was to write an application
to make the platforms.
There's revolutionary new
platform, paradigm shift,
everything, but the very first
thing you have to do to use it
is to create your own unit
of value on top of it.
And that's where we're at
right now. [INAUDIBLE].
All the tools are there, but
the teams that are using them
have to do a lot of
the heavy lifting
to sort of feel the value of it.
So I think, as an
industry, we have
to mature a little
bit in terms of having
solutions put together for
users that already go in there.
We need to write the dialer.
We need to write the camera app.
We need to write the
gallery app for you.
And that kind of stuff,
the general purpose
things that every
operations team needs just
to make the thing useful
to them is the challenges
that I think we're
getting through right now.
But the base platform,
it's getting pretty good.
And that's exciting.
CRAIG MCLUCKIE: I
agree with that.
I would add one
thing, which is thing
is really important
is, we have to create
effective standards around
some of the core pieces
that everyone wants to build on.
If you think what
containers are doing
is they're creating
a natural way
to express a piece of
software and describe
how you want it
run, and creating
a framework so you can actually
take that thing and run it.
And we need to create
a standard that
lets people really
innovate and advance
the story around the packaging
and distribution of containers,
continuous integration
and delivery,
new and unique ways to, you
know, to take code and actually
get into this environment,
secure operating
environments for these And we
need to do that in a way that
fosters a whole ecosystem.
And to do that, you
need to actually define
a clean standard.
And then on the
other side of it,
you need to be able to
consume that and run it
in a broad array
of technologies.
I mean, each of us
are vendors and have
our own set of offerings
that we need to consume.
It'd be kind of nice if there
was a standard that people
could really invest in,
that really decoupled
the production, the
consumption of technology.
And that's why I
think things like OCI
are incredibly important.
It's incredibly important
that OCI focus not just on--
KIT COLBERT: Sorry.
OCI, Open Container Initiative.
CRAIG MCLUCKIE: Open Container
Initiative, thank you.
Focus on really creating a
clean and sort of well adopted
standard that separates the
production and distribution
of container technologies from
the runtime and consumption
of it.
CORNELIUS WILLIS:
But standardization
on both sides of that?
CRAIG MCLUCKIE: Yeah.
So having a standard
sort of specification
so that the people who're
operating on the one
side of the divide
to actually want
to build and [INAUDIBLE]
containers can, you know,
work to that specification.
And then people
on the other side
of the divide, who want
to take those containers
and run them and operate them,
have a common ground to meet.
So that the tool providers
aren't trying to tool
for n different
providers' implementations
of the specification.
But that it also allows
each of the n providers
and specification to
create unique value
and differentiate
and actually offer up
real innovation in that space.
KIT COLBERT: Yeah.
And, you know, getting back to
the question around adoption
and, you know, the
maturity and the space.
So I think if you look at
what happened, let's say,
with VMware story and
the virtualization space.
I mean, that took a
good, I don't know,
let's say-- really started
this on the data center
started probably in 2000, 2001.
And just in the
last couple of years
have we reached
kind of the point
where people aren't afraid
to virtualize things anymore.
Before there was always
some kind of concerns.
And the concerns varied in
a number of different ways.
A lot of times it was just a
question of, you know, can I,
as an operations group, really
run this thing in production
with some sort of
assurance that it will run,
and, you know, I can take care
of problems when they happen,
and so forth.
And so I think what we've
seen is tremendous excitement
from developers because
developers get the value
proposition of containers.
You know, they get Docker and
they see how it can help them.
And so now I think that the
transition point is-- well,
sorry to fall on Craig's point
that we're seeing tooling come
out around this as well
throughout the CICD space,
and now over onto
the production side.
I think that's going to
be where the rubber meets
the road in terms of like,
as IT teams and operations
teams start to
take a look at this
and say, OK, how do we actually
run these things in production.
How do I make sure it's secure,
and how do I audit that,
and how do I monitor it,
and do I need to do backups?
You know, all the sort
of things that they
have to think through.
So I think what we're seeing
is-- I think this has actually
kind of evolved faster,
probably, than virtualization
did, just because the amount of
interest that's here right now,
and the amount of folks that
are jumping into the space.
But at the same time, I think
that right now it's very much,
for most of the
customers we talk to,
they're the kind of
cutting edge ones,
the ones who are willing to take
a bunch of this stuff that's
still kind of, you know,
just starting out and kind of
put it together in a
way that works for them.
And what you'll see
happening over time
is more out of the
box solutions, things
that just kind of work,
and are able to let
these IT teams take it and run.
CORNELIUS WILLIS: So what's
happening with Cloud-Native
Computing Foundation?
It seems kind of quiet lately.
What's the story?
CRAIG MCLUCKIE: OK.
I'm glad you asked the question.
So we've been
doing a lot of work
to basically put
together a framework
that we think will work
well for the community.
We're looking to really
create a foundation that
operates fairly, that has a
very strong technical identity
and technical
voice, that welcomes
a broad array of technologies,
but at the same time achieves
a convergence that
makes it useful.
So we've been
spending quite a lot
of time in a series
of conversations
through the community
channels to really get
the details of how
to make it run work.
And there's actually a lot of
effort and a lot of thought
is going into, you
know, how do we
create an effective
oversight committee that
isn't bound to a specific
commercial interest.
How do we create
a group of people
that are representing the end
users so that that voice isn't
drowned out by vendors that have
a strong commercial interest?
And then, you know,
how do we create
a principled architecture that
is, you know, fair to everyone
in the community, whether
they're end users and vendors,
and really sort of
bring it together.
So behind the scenes
we've been working really
hard to get a lot of
the details ironed out
about how it's going
to work, you know,
how things will be managed,
what the governing structure is,
and we're getting very
close to actually being
able to make a really, you know,
sort of strong announcement
around, you know, getting
through contracting
and actually starting
the day-to-day operations
of the foundation.
So things are going very well.
CORNELIUS WILLIS:
So assuming that we
have a successful
standards efforts,
and we're able to
link the development
world with the runtime
world through well-expressed
standards, what does a
thriving tool ecosystem
look like for containers?
ALEX POLVI: Sure, so I like
the standard shipping container
analogy a lot for this,
because it's very applicable.
So once we have our
standard on the unit,
you know, the goal is not
just to have a standard.
It's to have like
a global economy.
You know?
That's the point of this.
So by having a unit
that, as a user,
you can package against
and know that you have
a variety of vendors that
all interoperate with that,
you should see a rich
ecosystem of people
that are competing
for your business,
as well as some pretty good
innovations because of that.
If we have the bare minimum
piece of a standard, that
means, as vendors, we all
have to duke it out and like
earn your business.
Right?
We have to make our stuff
faster, more secure, and more
reliable, and so on.
So for the end user, the
standards create that.
And, again, using
the analogy here,
the goal is not
the standard, it's
the whole global economy
that's created because there's
that basic standard in place.
KIT COLBERT: Yeah.
I think Alex, you know,
hit on that with this--
and what we talk about when we
talk about this with customers,
the word that I hear a
lot to is optionality.
Right?
This ability to not get
locked into something,
that they can make choices
based on their requirements,
they can-- free to change
those choices as they need to.
And I think that's
kind of the vision
that we're all trying to get
to, where-- and by the way,
that's also a big
reason for open source.
We have a lot of open
source technologies.
And customers wanted to
leverage those things.
It, again, goes
back to optionality,
and multiple vendors backing
that open source project.
So I think, you know, when
we see the container space as
well, we don't want it to become
this super fragmented area
where, OK-- if that
happens, you'll
start making these crazy kind of
chains of dependency decisions,
like OK, so if I
select this technology,
then I can do that thing well,
this other thing not so well.
If I do this one, and
that one works OK.
And it's like, no.
Like let's make it very simple.
You do the default, standard
packaging, or whatever it is,
and then you have choices.
Do I want to use this sort
of technology for networking?
This one for storage?
This one for scheduling?
This one for consensus?
You know, it gives
you options and allows
you to leverage
the best of breed,
without getting locked into
anything down the road.
CORNELIUS WILLIS:
On the vendor side,
it also lets you
invest in the standard,
so you can innovate
off the standards--
KIT COLBERT: Exactly.
We make our solutions
better rather
than having five people
reinvent the wheel six times.
CRAIG MCLUCKIE: And I think
that actually is a key element
to driving innovation.
And to extend that to
other parts of the stack
as well, I think it
makes sense to try
to create a series of principled
interfaces between subsystems
so that if someone has a
really killer implementation
of something, they can
safely invest in that,
and innovate in it,
and actually have
it pulled through into a
variety of other areas.
And so I think, you know, really
pursuing that is important.
And I think, you know,
one thing I'd like to say,
which is kind of just
stepping back a little bit,
when I look to the future
here, a lot of things
are going to change.
And people try to play their
understanding of how operations
works into this new world.
And it's going to change.
We're going to create a
radical specialization of ops.
The number of
people you're going
to have to maintain to
operate a series of systems
is going to reduce, and
specialized operations
function is going to emerge.
And I expect each of
those operations functions
will have a unique set of tools.
And it should be
safe for providers
to really focus on
lighting those things up.
The container abstraction level
provides a remarkable amount
of data you could use for
things like intrusion detection,
if you want to drive security.
It'd be wonderful if an
ecosystem could emerge around
that.
So I think that's
likely to happen.
And then the other thing
I think is going to happen
is, you know, one of the things
we saw inside Google when
we made this transition
a long time ago is
this incredible explosion
in productivity.
Turns out, when you actually
make this transition to not
having to have your engineers
spend half their life
or more actually trying
to maintain and operate
the thing they just built-- but
that principled systems can run
them for them-- like they
become radically more
productive, radically
more code gets
produced, and you need new
classes of tools, and new ways
to actually define policy,
and see what's happening,
and track the things
that are being deployed.
So I think it's going
to introduce a very
substantive change in the
way that people actually
build and operate and
run these technologies.
And the actual set of
tools-- the suite of tools--
is going to evolve in
new and interesting ways.
CORNELIUS WILLIS: So what's
the preflight checklist?
Right?
If we look at, at
some point this
is going to become-- container
technology is going to become
the default packaging
mechanism, the default way
we develop software.
What's the preflight checklist
for how that happens?
When do we know
that we're there?
ALEX POLVI: Well.
I have an answer to that one.
I think, so, it's
really about the user.
And when the user is able to
package their application once,
sign it-- which means it's them
saying this is my package--
and then run it across
a variety of vendors--
they can choose Google
Container Engine,
they can choose the
VMware products,
they can choose
Tectonic from CoreOS,
like these different things
or any other vendor that
wants to interoperate
with that standard--
but the user can take that unit.
He can say, this is mine.
And then they can run
it in their own place
of their choosing.
I think that's
when we've done it,
we actually have
interoperability,
and standardization,
and choice for users.
KIT COLBERT: And
I think it's going
to take the classic sort
of adoption curve, right?
Where you're going to have some
people on the leading edge who
are willing to like
roll up their sleeves,
and do the extra work, and
sort through the myriad number
of options, and just
make it work, right?
And deal with some of
the issues of the changes
and so forth that
happen down the road.
But I think we're
definitely going
to hit an inflection
point where it is
kind of ready for mass market.
And that sort of the
point that Alex is making.
Is that there's going to be a
point at which the stuff works
well enough out of the
box, the early adopters
have figured out a lot
the hard problems around
operationalizing these things
and production, and some
of the other issues there.
And then-- we're
always trying to do--
the cool about the
container space
is that it really
is a community.
If you go to any of like the
meet ups, or the conferences,
you see a lot of people
sharing their experiences.
Like here is, you know-- at
a company, I took this thing,
we started running it, and
here's all the problems I hit,
and here's how to avoid
those in the future.
So as we collect that sort
of knowledge as an industry
and as a community,
it will help everyone
who's new to that
community even go faster.
CRAIG MCLUCKIE: Yeah,
I agree with that.
I think every customer's
going to be different.
We already have a lot
of customers that are,
you know, they roll out these
amazing statistics around how
it's changed the
way that they take
the technology to production.
And they're able to go from
one roll out every two weeks
to multiple roll outs a day,
that their operations are
sort of [INAUDIBLE].
So for a lot of the
fore leading people,
it's been ready
for quite a while,
and they're already
benefiting from it.
At the far end of the
spectrum, a lot of folks
need developer
training to actually
become familiar with the tools.
They need their favorite systems
integrated to actually develop
a practice around this and
that, to actually fully
inculcate and acquire a
staff that can actually
support their needs.
And so, it's going to trickle
through technology exactly
as VMs did.
Right?
Like if you think about
that VM adoption cycle.
It took eight years
or however long
to really become prevalent.
I think it'll
probably go quicker
because, to Kitt's
point, there's
a lot of interest around it.
But I think every customer
will make their decision based
on their specific needs around
completeness of tooling,
willingness to
engage in open source
and actually participate in the
evolution of the open source
technology, their
vendor providing them
a comprehensive suite
of tools that they need,
their systems integration
partners actually being there
to help them through some
of the transition processes.
So I don't think there's
a one phase answer,
but it's going a lot
faster that I expected,
is what I would say.
CORNELIUS WILLIS:
So with that, I
think we've had a good, grown up
conversation about containers.
No chairs were thrown.
Nobody stalked off the set.
That's good.
KIT COLBERT: Success.
CORNELIUS WILLIS: Success.
So thank you all for
joining us today.
And thank you for watching.
As I think you can hear,
this is the coming framework
for how we will write
and run software.
So our encouragement to you is
to go out and learn about it.
And there are lots of
resources, from all three
of these vendors, about
container technology.
So go try it out.
Go work with it.
Thanks so much for joining us.